going back to your
uh your freshman cover in 2010 that was
a
in retrospect one of the most historical
covers
i think they ever had at double excel
was you it was nip
it was big sean it was fred it was
j-rock
j-rock was on uh cole was on there like
such like like how crazy like do you
ever like look back and
and kind of reflect on like some of your
moments in hip hop because that's like a
historical moment man
yeah yeah it's dope um
when you're coming up you always you
look at the past and be like oh man i
wish i would have
came up during that time but we
definitely had our own era where it was
like that was
our golden era you could say it was like
how it was when
tribe was out yeah it was like i always
looked my favorite era was the blog era
that was our own version of that and we
lived it too we were
couch surfing we were flight hopping we
were concert
going we were studio sleeping
we was really thugging and we everybody
was helping each other out so it was all
the
like you said the blog era we made the
music and then the blogs put it out so
we had
it was the relationship it was always
fun to find new artists on like two dope
boys
like those days it was like it was just
it felt like that the
curators there was more of a selection
to where you knew if you went to a
certain website you find some [ __ ] that
you're looking for i feel like nowadays
the curators like a few people at these
dsps
it was hard to get into those things too
like you really had to be dope
no for sure but it was like but they
would also take chances on artists yeah
for sure
i mean for show you they would post one
thing if it didn't get that many likes
they would still post another one
yeah thinking man this popularity
contest now
um which is cool it's it's not that bad
but
that [ __ ] only lasts what 15 seconds so
yeah i feel like the streaming [ __ ] is
cool but it's like also
it's made it extremely i wouldn't say
hard but i feel like
you it's harder than ever to
[Music]
start from scratch and have a career
because you really got there's like a
few
i'm someone on some independent [ __ ]
there's you know you got to get on carl
cherry's radar you got to get on
you know whoever's to really kind of
break through some of those um editorial
playlists do you think so
i think so man i think you just gotta
get a good 15 seconds
what do you mean like over song that's
it mm-hmm
you're good right yeah you have to have
a whole song you have 15 seconds a nice
little hook
tick-tock a little something that loops
put it on tick-tock you're good
hey you had a tick-tock moment something
new you made a little the fans did that
that's something new but i was like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is like two years old
exactly yeah fans did that that was cool
as hell
that happened during the pandemic too it
did it did everybody was at home with
their families
take talking it up using the app and all
that